alors pierre juquin vous avez vous êtes
entré au parti communiste en 53 vous
allez supporter l'époque déjà
d'interruption elle en allemagne de
l'est à berlin vous avez supporté
budapest 156 tchécoslovaquie en 68 vous
avez participé à l'exclusion d'un
certain nombre de vos camarades et
aujourd'hui quel effet ça fait d'être
exclue vous même ce n'est pas mon
principal problème parce que je compte
la situation beaucoup évolué depuis
d'autre part il ya deux ans j'ai écrit
un livre qui s'appelait autocritique et
ça n'est pas de la frime j'essaie de
faire le bilan de tous a dit réfléchir
freinant et j'avais deux solutions ou me
mettre à écrire des romans ou des essais
ou essayer de repartir je ne dirais pas
et romain tenant compte de tout cela et
de tout ce qui s'est fait en dehors de
moi pendant ce temps pour continuer une
bataille disons humaniste vous rejoignez
la cohorte des repentis du pc est
finalement sorti je trouve ce mot très
mauvais je vais vous dire pourquoi
peut-être pas que ce que vous pensez
parce que moi je ne suis jamais rentré
dans le communisme comme rentre dans une
église mais je pense qu'il faut enfin
laïcisé ce genre de politique dans le
parti communiste j'ai beaucoup appris
moi qui suis un intellectuel évidemment
d'origine très modeste et tout blâme
intellectuelle et j'en suis fier et
heureux je voudrais l'être encore plus
j'ai rencontré là des gens de tous les
milieux du monde du travail je me
permets d'écrire mineurs - cheminots en
direct vous transforme y en a qui
parlent des gens vous avez vous avait
exclu à l'époque où des choses
insupportables que vous avez supporté
c'est vous le regrettez pas il aura
rendu service
en partie que
des
explosions j'en ai pas tellement exprimé
j'ai couvert des types de politiques non
je pas exclu à la crise j'ai couvert un
petit mieux les étudiants communes
esprit en 65 une bataille j'ai couvert
un type de politique est nommé de quoi
vous vite et qui est très préjudiciable
la cause de qui est la mienne celle du
changement profond de société ce que
vous voulez pas dire en amoureux et
passez un plus
monsieur g15 rénovateurs ps eut lcr sos
racisme etc enjeux écologistes n'ont pas
peur d'être le candidat pour tous la
prochaine élection présidentielle si
j'étais le candidat fourre-tout je me
retirerai lorsque ça je ne devrais pas
je crois qu'il s'agit de faire quelque
chose de cohérent de sérieux je dirais
de morale là la chose qui mobilise le
plus et qui est quand même le point de
départ de ma réflexion critique demande
examen de conscience c'est que j'en ai
assez de cette politique ou le faire et
de dire c'est pas le vérifier dans les
gens qui vous soutiennent on retrouve
des gens comme alain krivine qui ont été
quand même vos ennemis non ça nous fait
rien devant d'heures travaillées que
tout est si je pouvais être un
réconciliateur un fédérateur de gens
extrêmement différent je serais très
content mais je crois que faut pas
focaliser sur krilin sur x ou y est pas
faire naître un peu le jaubert de la
gauche
celui d ailleurs en fait on ne sait pas
où il est moi je sais très bien où je
suis parce que les gens qui sont avec
moi c'est pas krivine etc je suis
candidat donc une oreille le soutien qu
une seule tribune vous soutiens qui va
me suivre mais je suis le candidat
plutôt des gens d'un certain nombre de
gens qui se sont battus dans le
mouvement social ou qui s'y battent le
mouvement antiraciste le mouvement des
étudiants ils se tiennent pas dans leur
ensemble et en tant que tel mais y'en a
beaucoup ils sont auprès de moi c'est
les red immense joie moi je vais vous
dire au mois de
octobre septembre dernier exactement un
an je songe à me retirer de la politique
active de la vie publique c'est quand
même assez dur est devant ce mouvement
des étudiants auxquels a participé par
exemple mon fils je me suis dit il ya
quelque chose à faire et c'est une joie
formidable de me voir avec david
assouline qui haïssent ati tous et
beaucoup d'autres gens qui incarnent ce
mouvement excusez moi tu crois qu'il a
des chances de faire des poids jusqu'à
j'ai toujours pensé que s'il ne restait
quelques cas il serait celui là
à propos de ce que vous avez dit vous
avez raison en disant il ay là il a fait
tout ça il a accepté euro la hongrie
budapest tout ça c'est du moins ce que
je crois c'est que
personne ni personnellement je pense
qu'il faut pas reprocher éternellement
aux gens ce qu'ils ont fait à marquer à
tout faire mais attendez à partir du
moment où on est fait il dit je me suis
trompé j'ai dit des bêtises j'ai fait
des choses condamnables je prendrai des
gens armés a guère parce que ce soit à
voile à l'adoration n'aurait pas dû une
fois là est ce que je veux dire
l'honneur on la comparait ce nom mais
j'allais prendre moi-même cette cette
comparaison on dit toujours faut-il
éternellement
rechercher à faire le procès des gens
qui ont été collaborateur ou côté
vichysme je dis non si quelqu'un
aujourd'hui qui a été vicié se dit mais
c'est horrible j'en ai honte j'en dors
pas la nuit etc jeudi mais il faut
complètement oublié le seul problème
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
continuent à être vichyste ou qui
continuent à trouver qu'ils avaient
raison d'être collaborer n'a pas eu le
temps alors de dollars il faut être
implacables ouais totalement un placard
mais quand quelqu'un reconnaîtra dans
tout le monde s'est trompé un moment
donné joliment tout le monde tout le
monde a été ou maoïste ou communistes ou
ou petit nice to ou accrue au socialisme
au libéralisme thuriau tout le monde
s'est trompé donc forcément si on veut
faire quelque chose on ne peut le faire
qu'avec les gens qui reconnaissent
qu'ils se sont trompés forcément alors
faisons de la grande unité des gens qui
reconnaissent qu'ils se sont trompés le
parc en doses et ses centres ont fait
contre les gens qui continuent à se
tromper voilà les corrections de nous
raté l'oin a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux